hello guys and welcome to another video
so this will be a pretty quick but
exciting video as we have a new rumor
that the love and thunder trailer will
be dropping next week so a scooper known
by nick santos says that you'll be able
to tell when the trailer for love and
thunder will release by counting the
number of sleeves on both hands so this
means from right now from today the
trailer will supposedly release between
six to 10 days now if you're wondering
how reliable is this scooper can we
trust this person well nick has actually
confirmed a release date for three
previous trailers so the second
multiverse of madness trailer he said
would premiere on super bowl that turned
out to be true he then said the mess
marvel trailer will be premiering this
week which that just came out and then
he also said when the obi-wan trailer
would release and have released exactly
on that date so the previous three
trailers has been spot on so this leads
me to believe that the release date for
the love and thunder trailer could
actually be next week between 6 to 10
days from today although despite being
super reliable for the previous three
trailers i would still recommend taking
this with a grain of salt as with rumors
and scoops and leaks you never know what
is true and what is false so just take
with a grain of salt but nevertheless
it's pretty exciting that we could see
the love and thunder trailer next week
you know that's pretty much about it for
this video guys let me know what do you
want to see from the love and funder
trailer and do you think it will release
next week let me know in the comment
section below if you haven't already
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching